hey this is really good Fox News host
Jesse Watters got completely trolled by
a fake and Tifa activist Jesse Watters
is known in some circles as a sort of
protege to the now disgraced Bill
O'Reilly on Fox News and he set up an
interview with the supposed and Tifa
activists now auntie feh stands for
anti-fascist
and this anti-fur group is actually
known for some of the rare violence on
the left and Jesse Watters clearly
thought I'm gonna get this guy on and
we're gonna talk to him about all the
bad violent things that an Tifa is doing
and it's all gonna be just absolutely
tremendous and it turns out that they
interviewed a completely fake troll who
calls himself BG kumbi who gave the name
Kevin to the producers of Jesse Watters
now just because they got trolled
doesn't mean that the interview didn't
accomplish exactly what Jesse Watters
wanted to accomplish I'm gonna talk
about that a little bit later here's a
little bit of this interview where BG
kumbi has Kevin the ante fapri tester
from the boston-based chapter of anti
feh explains why he doesn't want to give
his full name Kevin who doesn't want to
give his last name represents the Antipa
branch of Boston and he wrote that
letter he joins me now via Skype
so Kevin why don't you want us to use
your last name what are you afraid of oh
you see what happened with CNN they they
basically Doc's that guy that made that
that give so you're afraid if your name
is out there people are gonna come to
your house of course okay yeah so
there's a lot in this interview that
should have maybe suggested to the Fox
News team that this is a ruse this is a
prank if you google search Boston and
Tifa you would find that Boston and Tifa
is affiliated with a satire website run
by right-wingers in Oregon
you might also realize that actual
antifoam members and I know that it's
sort of like what is an actual
Tifa member it's not like you've got a
membership card but in any case they
they don't really appear on TV with
their faces visible they usually wear
you know some kind of a bandana covering
their face or whatever the case may be
the most ridiculous moment from the
interview I believe was when Jesse
Watters wanted to call out BG kumbi
about this thing that took place in
Pennsylvania where an anti feh activist
stabbed a horse and the following is
what happened are you familiar with the
violent actions that your group has
perpetrated you gotta take my word for
it isn't self-defense against right-wing
aggression was it in self-defense when
you firebomb the limousine during the
inauguration yes okay because the owner
of the limousine is a Muslim immigrant
were you aware of that well you know a
lot of violence committed by so-called
Antipa members is actually committed by
these right-wingers who basically seek
to make us look bad okay so the Muslim
immigrant who owned the limo that was
firebombed was trying to make you look
bad how I don't think he's the one that
firebombed it's these right-wing
infiltrators you see it all the time all
over the internet for groups have been
stabbed a police horse in the neck with
a knife was the horse racist Trump
supporter yes so okay so this reminds me
of when Fox News fell for a fake former
Obama supporter this is a classic video
just a reminder we covered the story a
couple years ago it's amazing his recent
college grad max rice he voted for
President Obama now he's unemployed and
Jen just moved out of his parents home
good morning to you max hello mrs. Miss
USA it's an honor miss I can see you
that's America Miss Universe in my book
in my book oh okay well well thank you
very much now tell me your story you
believed in the hope and change of
President Obama and so you voted for him
and tell me about the next huge bomb a
supporter in 2008 I met him in third
grade when I was little okay and why now
are you supporting me
your question right now are you
supporting Mitt Romney it's actually a
funny story
I lost a basketball game to a friend of
mine not like Stern is a huge support of
the show okay so it sounds like you're
not being very sad I'm also disappointed
in the direction that I've almost taking
this nation okay so anyway this is this
has happened to Fox News before here's
the really serious thing though Jesse
Watters wanted to make an Tifa look bad
and BG kumbi wanted to make an Tifa look
bad and they succeeded so it actually is
sort of irrelevant to the average
trumpet who's already predisposed to
hate an T fuh when they see this they're
going to come away thinking wow what a
group of horrible absolutely terrible
people and there are of course
legitimate criticisms of the people in
ante fuh but it's irrelevant that Fox
News got trolled because everybody got
out of it what they wanted which is to
make an Tifa look bad even though the
entire thing is fake especially because
it seems like BJ calm B's motive wasn't
necessarily to you know make Fox News in
particular and the right-wingers look
bad just to go after the media and stir
up the pot wherever he could absolutely
and to that extent it worked it
absolutely worked and you know what most
of the people who saw this which
reportedly reportedly when Trump was
flying back from something this is what
was on TV on Air Force One when Trump
was watching Fox News that's been
reported and which is amazing most
people are not gonna ever find out that
the entire thing was bogus
at first I thought this may have
happened because they're just falling
behind in the ratings so maybe they
don't have as much for background
research on these interview guests
they've trimmed this has been happening
all along this happened a few years ago
with the other guest has happened
multiple times on Fox News many
discussions about this on our reddit
discussion forum david pakman.com slash
re d di t